right now police in north las vegas are
looking for a driver who left a man dead
right in the middle of the road this all
happening near simmons and alexander the
man in his 20's was in the road when
police suspect someone hit and killed
him they think that because of his
injuries jeremy j ford telling us what
we know so far about this investigation
just because i personally don't know the
person it's heartbreaking to see it
happen beau jordan is a personal friend
of the man who died he says people need
to slow down especially when driving
through a residential neighborhood
because usually because then just
like such a straight path
people use it as like a straightaway
just fly just so they can see how fast
that car goes for a few times which can
cause accidents leaving family members
behind to bear the burden i see when new
someone gets it i'm like wow that's
unfortunate but having it happened to
someone so close to you it's like it
hits a different part of your heart and
he has these words of advice for the
driver who killed his friend honestly
from what had happened
just
turn yourself in for it because
there's no like i don't know i don't
really have any bad words it's just
what goes wrong comes around and it's
going to happen sooner or later jeremy j
ford live local now